- [Teacher] The function g is
defined over the real numbers.
This table gives select values of g.
What is a reasonable
estimate for the limit
is x approaches five of g of x?
So pause this video, look at this table.
It gives us the x values
as we approach five
from values less than five
and as we approach five
from values greater than five
it even tells us what g
of x is at x equals five.
And so, given that, what
is a reasonable estimate
for this limit?
Alright now let's work
through this together.
So let's think about what g
of x seems to be approaching
as x approaches five from
values less than five.
Let's see at four is it 3.37,
4.9? It's a little higher.
Is it 3.5, 4.99? Is it 3.66?
4.999; so very close to five.
We're only a thousandth
away, we're at 3.68.
But then at five all of a sudden
it looks like we're
kind of jumping to 6.37.
And once again, I'm
making an inference here.
I don't, these are just sample points
of this function, we don't know exactly
what the function is.
But then if we approach five
from values greater than five.
At six we're at 3.97;
at 5.1 we're at 3.84.
5.01; 3.7; 5.001;
we're at 3.68.
So a thousandth below five
and a thousandth above five
we're at 3.68, but then at five
all of sudden we're at 6.37.
So my most reasonable estimate
would be, well it look like
we're approaching 3.68.
When we're approaching
from values less than five.
And we're approaching 3.68 from values
as we approach five from
values greater than five.
It doesn't matter that
the value of five is 6.37.
The limit would be 3.68 or
a reasonable estimate for
the limit would be 3.68.
And this is probably the
most tempting distractor here
because if you were to
just substitute five;
what is g of five?
It tells us 6.37, but the limit does not
have to be what the actual
function equals at that point.
Let me draw what this might look like.
So an example of this, so if
this is five right over here,
At the point five the value of my function
is 6.37, so let's say
that this right over here
is 6.37, so that's the value
of my function right over there.
So 6.37, but as we approach five,
so that's four, actually let
me spread out a little bit.
This obviously is not drawing to scale.
But as we approach five,
so if this, that's 6.37;
then at four, 3.37 is about here
and it looks like it's approaching 3.68.
So 3.68, actually let me draw that.
So 3.68 is gonna be roughly that.
3.68 is gonna be roughly that.
So the graph, the graph might
look something like this.
We can infer it looks like
it's doing something like this.
Where it's approaching 3.68
from values less than five
and values greater than
five, but right at five,
our value is 6.37.
I don't know for sure if this
is what the graph look like
once again, we're just
getting some sample points.
But this would be a reasonable inference.
And so you can see, our limit.
We are approaching 3.68,
even though the value
of the function is something different.